beirut cumple un mes tras la explosión y
lo hace con resignación ayer el ejército
libanés encontró en el puerto cuatro
toneladas más de nitrato de amonio la
sustancia explosiva que supuestamente
provocó la tragedia del pasado 4 de
agosto el primer ministro en funciones
hasan diab ha sido interrogado en la
investigación por la explosión hasta
ahora ninguna de las 25 detenciones que
se han practicado ha tenido vinculación
con altos cargos a pesar de que varios
documentos demuestran que tenían
conocimiento de la presencia de los
explosivos en el puerto de beirut
mientras tanto el barrio de sema y se
lleva en vilo 24 horas a noche equipos
de rescate chilenos advirtieron de la
presencia de dos cuerpos bajo la runa a
uno de ellos supuestamente el de un niño
le detectaron posibles signos de vida
anuncian que sus dispositivos no son
100% fiables y que un milagro es
improbable pero aún así han estado toda
la noche siguiendo con los trabajos de
rescate ayer las autoridades locales
querían bloquear la búsqueda durante la
noche hasta el día siguiente pero la
presión popular les hizo cambiar de
opinión